oggi stiamo per portare un regalo allora
le mie aspettative sono altissime che
per le da mesi che parliamo di questa
roba
gli ho detto quanto spendono già sparita
però non sai cos'è no viene amico mi
faccio allora innanzitutto ti devo
mostrare dove questo regalo goduto e
siccome è un qualcosa di moto sinistra
l'ho dovuta a nascondere ok li provati
lì dove dico ora sotto il letto nelle
armani invece è stato eletto precedenza
prodotto ok perché io dico aprile
[Musica]
lo dichiara se ne faceva cento ma no che
bracciano che prossimo regalano un letto
allora il regalo amico mio è incartata
ci voglio crepare sanerà giga protesi ma
tira fuori
no no non ci piacciono però io comunque
un po di forza fisica ciano ed è
veramente
pesante di prendere tutta la forza se
una marea di iscritti ed è andato tutto
la mia mente
quest'amore uk è però se entrava mia
madre quindi io non sapevo ma
giustificate e damiani ha visto ancora
guardando la new team top però toccano
una cosa presti cosa adesso riprende
guardando ancora la telecamera ad amare
vado grosso per guardare 18 ritiene che
studenti o mio dio ma due ragazze ci
sono anche quei gadget che sono né così
bianchi che puoi prendere
no ragazzino fa prossimo
houllier
[Musica]
rim un ernia mela pochi colombo ne frega
niente
può dire che sia per la scena certi non
va
sei contento di questo video era volte
prima di arrivare a casa tua
[Musica]
cosi mi faccio capire che cosa ho fatto
prudenti non sono ammazzato ragazzi è il
momento di andare a fare gli auguri a
marco e poi vi presenteremo giusto
regalo però andiamo prima a fargli gli
auguri
marcolino
niente volevo farti gli auguri di qua
ragazzi oggi io allora io ascolto e non
posso fare io come una persona senza
riprendere non è vero perché se libri 30
anni e quindi io ho fatto un video
proprie motional su come si come
festeggiare una persona e oggi sono qua
infatti gli auguri anche a regalo però
prima vuole veramente dirti quanto per
me se l'interessato ma mi farò per
coordinare lo stop legato che si tiene
questo video proprio motion azione senza
e serio quindi volevo farti proprio un
discorso che spero tu apprezzerai perché
ci permettono negli ultimi anni ci
conosciamo la 34 anni seriamente da tre
anche se alle volte ci sono
contrarissimo sono trovati bene è vero
ma lo abbiamo riso molto perché per me
la tua amicizia veramente tanto perché
tu sei l'unica persona sul molto serio
che mi ha insegnato negli ultimi anni
negli ultimi tre anni ad apparire alle
persone come si è cioè non devi sparire
le persone come come vogliono loro ma
come vuoi tu
e in questo punto richiamarti dato che
mi morello una persona che meglio
l'illusione esatto
ed è questo modo che ti fa apprezzare
dagli altri perché per la pena non devi
fingere di essere un'altra persona
vicente stesso quel tu stai bene con te
stesso e persone stanno bene con te se
si trovano bene
sono d'accordissimo quindi questa cosa
può essere presa sotto gamba ma in
realtà io giuro importantissima è
veramente impone nella più importante è
il signor noi siano tu mi stai
scherzando
è invece per mese cioè tante persone
nella mia vita mi insegnano cose questa
è una cosa molto importante e va
insegnata solo tu sono quindi per me
donazioni io però
emozionato anche quelli che questi
trent'anni
niente ci festeggiamo ma niente ho fatto
regalino come stabile per voi ragazzi è
molto molto bello e quindi ti riprendi
riprendi grazie danni che mi ha trovati
qua non ho finito però insomma marco io
ti voglio bene spero che questo
significa che qualcosa aperture
[Musica]
ma è una e una realt all allora oggi ti
voglio raccontare una cosa ma io amo le
sale demonetizzazione in corso succede
vediamo perché perché poi veramente la
professione del discorso per scopi esse
stesse stessi scusa sono mozione poi
sempre l'immaginazione per migliorarle e
per renderle diverse mi ricordo un
giorno entra e su realdon dot.com quei
prezzi la diciamo che hanno un po fatto
calare la ripida come sottile mai avrei
immaginato
come stessero si legano e chi diventa
una cosa il solito io sono per
l'esagerazione gente non lo sa bene
perché lavoriamo insieme abbiamo fatto
il massimo di quello che dovevi fare
rispetto alle istruzioni prima tu mi hai
dato tanto io volevo darti daniele vedo
che la guardi da un'ora interrotto 20
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto e
io faccio gli auguri anche una volta a
marco che per questi 30 anni si
meritavano regola legge e lo ringrazio
per essere sempre mio amico la famiglia
di sorridere
io ho cercato di essere serio spero di
esserci riuscito perché con quel momento
molto emozionato ci sono riuscito viste
faccio passi da gigante ma ha insegnato
anche 2 west un bacio lasciate piace e
noi ci vediamo prossimo compleanno
piccola cozzolino di chiudere mi trovi
coletti vendicherò in un modo e
sicuramente anche dell'altro va bene
[Musica]